we are live hello everybody and welcome
to a very exciting afternoon
I am here with the handsome and cool and
smart Jeremy P I'll let him say what's
up in a second but uh I want to say
what's up to everybody on Instagram
because you're outside of the comments I
see I see the comments coming in from
YouTube LinkedIn and Facebook over here
on my right side
um and everybody on Instagram the link
to the full stream
um is on my YouTube on my Twitter or if
you want to leave this live stream and
go to my regular Instagram and just hit
uh the Link Card porn what's good it was
nice meeting all of you uh Scotty good
to see you like the sauce great to so
much happiness you're here modern hippie
great to see you at Pecan I'm Excuse me
at the national the national felt like
vcon Jeremy we had a great event we'll
get into that in a minute but we are
here to announce something that I think
is one of the most significant days in
uh in in V friends IP history can you
help me with this in be friends IP
history I would argue that there have
been very few sustained phenomenons to
the level of squishmallows I I believe
that is because of the quality of the
product personally not just the pop
culture hit uh and for us to be able to
be officially announcing
um this partnership in this format
um is a huge huge deal Instagram there's
the squishmallows I know that you can
see them up here uh I the camera's a
little far away from me it's not on my
screen as you can see
um we'll get that towards the end but
um I'm humbled I would I would tell all
of you that are watching one of my great
dreams when I started this IP was the
licensing deals that we would make and
where would I take this brand and what
would I do with these characters and
obviously the trading cards thing is hot
and heavy off of the national
we launched an nft form we continue to
be overly invested in the digital
landscape Jeremy right the concept of
and not or com you can collect comic
books and training cards you can collect
watches and wine I think the world loves
or in Collectibles I think people think
they're fighting for share of wallet too
much but I think it's a blended
you know path when you're an
intellectual property and I would argue
that it is every current intellectual
property's dream to do a collab with
squishmallows so I am humbled I am
honored I know that this is going to be
the entry for a lot of people there's a
ton of people who've already I mean
here's the story actually you know what
before I get I'm already too excited
Jeremy why are you saying hello why
don't you tell everybody who you are and
we will get into this but I've got a
good story right off the bat all right
well first of all you survived Nationals
well well done we look like we might be
in the same room in fact I I would love
to spend a few minutes staring at what
you got behind you a little ADHD is uh
my middle name so uh very awesome to see
all that stuff yeah so I'm Jeremy padour
I'm Chief brand officer at jazz Wares
and we are the number four toy company
it's uh we we're just uh acquired
Believe It or Not by Berkshire Hathaway
last October
um it's been amazing to see something
grow up like this and and we did it
based on Trend we focused on gaming we
focused on social media based stuff so
Pokemon and Halo and fortnite and Roblox
and and then uh you know from a social
media side things like Coco melon we
were very first there and we had to rely
on areas where the big toy companies
were not playing because it's nearly
impossible to compete in a very mature
category unless you try to do something
new and interesting and uh but we're
very passionate toy people and as
passionate toy people I see it as
passionate toy people I'll tell you this
um it's all about the love so we squish
Mellows is a phenomenon you you very you
were right on when you said sustained
and how unusual that is and maybe we can
talk about that and and look I'm gonna
pan out I'll show you a little bit of my
squish Milos at the top there too I bet
some I've got some Warren and Charlie
and I've got some limited editions up
there but uh no no bottom line uh you
know for me started a toy company we got
acquired by Jazz Wares combined our
efforts uh bought Kelly toy which was
squishmallows early got there really
early we just had really good Vision in
this organization Judd zaberski is our
CEO Laura zaberski is our president and
myself the chief real quick I'm sorry to
interrupt you because this is a fun one
right off the top and you know how I
like the Royal germ uh cor said new
Beanie Babies and I was saying to
somebody at the national they're like
why do you you know a lot of people
discovered be friends at the national
yeah went home the first night Googled
it the first thing that came up was the
squishmallows announcement because we
just announced
came back the next day and said oh my
god I didn't even know about be friends
yesterday I saw your crazy Booth I got a
pack or a sticker we did a lot of smart
things at the national I Googled last
night I'm gonna buy all of them for my
son or daughter because they're crazy
about squishmallows that happened like
two or three times I was talking to the
team over dinner one night and the
Beanie Babies thing got brought up and I
said the difference was eighty percent
of the people that were buying beanie
babies at that era were buying it for
the purpose of flipping it or its value
95 of the people that buy squishmallows
buy it to use it
yes there's bushmelo's community that
collects and flips but it is a minuscule
percentage of that market it's it is a
functional toy that people that
grown-ups
are addicted to from a comfort
standpoint
and so I don't even see them remotely
the same
I see this more like Cabbage Patch Kids
and Power Rangers and Tickle Me Elmo
where there's an element of the
collectibility in it
it's the sizzle the stake is the product
and actually more than even the three
toys that I just named the form factor
and the utility of the form factor
is like a is like like there's a 25
pillow business in this
and I think you I think what you have is
remarkable so that was the answer to the
gentleman who said it's you know I think
you can't even compare the two they're
totally different and that's why oh by
the way
they acted different this has now been
around for quite a long time sustained
well your intuition is so strong
um and that comes from a lot of places
uh but but yes I mean squishmallows has
been built on something very organic and
not on a false premise there's no false
premise it just is what it is it's a
it's a huggable lovable collectible
world of over 2 000 characters we've
almost sold 300 million units and it's
getting it's gotten bigger every single
year it was actually launched in 2017 at
Walgreens believe it or not and it was
launched as a form factor just something
that was uh very much was exciting to
our design team the design team now at
jazz Wares and you know sometimes when
you're dealing with Brands and you
launch Brands you have to have an
enormous investment behind them you know
maybe there's a license maybe there's a
movie maybe there's a deal with Disney
or some other major IP holder but
sometimes and especially in the plush
category you can try things and this was
really a form factor that from the very
first day hit just based on what it
looked like and the easy easy
translation to practically everything
and it was protectable because there
really wasn't a lot like it out there at
the time everything had arms and legs
and but yeah this this is a this is it's
it's truly a remarkable story and it's
an unusual one but you're right and and
you know for me I have to be careful
about disparaging but I will say that
there are other brands that have existed
that have been existing on a false
premise it was all about value or
collectible or you buy these in your
kids college is going to be taken care
of we've never made any claim whatsoever
that there's a secondary Market
collectibility but part of our strategy
is certainly to develop some more
limited edition product and and have
things that that will Delight collectors
kids adults on their various levels but
yeah your your spot on in terms of the
way you were intuitively thinking about
that what's uh
just real quick for everybody on
Instagram and for everybody on YouTube
LinkedIn and Facebook watching this
right now please answer really quick
who here has squishmallows in their home
simple yes no in both chats please real
quick because we're gonna get you know
usually I'm rushed in these we got a
little bit time here which is nice I
always love to be with you Jeremy
because I think you have a great give me
a yes or no I see an I do Josh that was
not right yes or no simple yes or no
um
most staggering staggering amount I
would say quick hot take the team will
probably do this but I would say at
least 70 30 60 40 and I have a lot of I
have an audience that's not the perfect
pocket for you a lot of 23 to 32 year
olds which I know a lot of them get into
but as you can imagine if this audience
was predominantly 10 and under or 45 and
older or 38 and older as the parents
demo so like the high percentage of yes
I think mine's probably the most
challenging demo because if there's any
middle pocket there's that in between of
Parenthood and childhood even though I'm
aware because I'm paying attention to
everything how many teenagers in your
early 20s love the crap out of this
obviously the hot steam is parents and
and children so look this is really
penetrated
you know I guess my question since I
wanted to ask that question because I
wanted to get a chance to understand
where to take these questions so now
that I see it's a 70 30 kind of split
what's the most exciting thing going on
in squishmallow land for the 30 percent
that don't know or to give a little
Alpha to the 70 that you know
you know I have to say that's what we
thought too we thought that the older
age consumer was going to be the
secondary market for squishmallows like
it like traditional plush Brands because
if you look at the history of
Collectibles and secondary Market
valuation most of that's been driven by
things that are plastic dolls action
figures those types of things have
created secondary market and Beanie
Babies was a great example of a plush
item that did have secondary
um you can see it in in other brands
like gunned and and stife and brands
that have been out there for a very long
time
but we did our study in 2020 right
before the pandemic hit and we were
shocked to find that our primary
purchaser was older than 12. and that at
the time at the time by the way
switchmost is around one-tenth the size
as it is right now right now it's the
number one
toy or collectible property in the world
which is shocking to all of us but uh
number two right now from a from a toy
perspective from a toy and card
perspective is Pokemon which we also
have which has been the blessing of our
lives but the bottom line is so the
things that are exciting uh we have 60
licensing Partners um and growing it
could be a hundred by the end of the
year and those licensing Partners cover
things like you know Footwear and we
have some amazing timepiece
collaboration coming out
um we have east side games which is
launching a gaming in the mobile space
um some content that will be coming out
from from a streaming standpoint and we
have to be very careful with content
because it can't be kid-like it can't
just be kid it has to be innocent but it
can't just be for little kids because
that's just one part of our overall
market and I imagine that you're sort of
feeling similarly as you're developing V
friends as a brand a very similar
characteristics yeah I mean I think I'm
sorry yeah you know I'm trying to make
this as valuable for a lot I have a
feeling actually before I go there which
for everybody's watching Pretty
entrepreneurs who are debating to build
their own IP or collectible business I'm
actually going to go in a different
place something hit me about a year ago
and it's been really
uh manifesting and um
kind of fermenting in the the lab this I
call this the lab
um
much like music Sports
movies TV
and fashion
these have those categories are now
essential parts of life
Jeremy Wright you and I get to meet we
go out with our plus ones we go over
dinner and
we
um
we get to know each other it's a
couple's dinner
very quickly after family what do you do
for a living you know you're now 35
minutes into the dinner
we're going into what shows are you
watching
you know what do you guys like to do on
vacation
obviously you wore close to it and I'm
going to show up to that dinner as a 47
year old and a T-shirt and a hat and
sneakers I'm projecting that I'm chill
like I'm casual I'm not wearing like
which is fine because I am other people
may wear a great suit and everything
with a great watch and they're
presenting what they're into which is
the craftsmanship some people blast
Brands and their brand life like
everyone's allowed to do their thing
I've realized oh my God
collecting
the whole genre
is on the Press business within the next
decade or two of being a genre I believe
in 15 to 20 years
it is a cultural genre that you will go
out to dinner or you meet something
literally you meet somebody at a
business meeting and you go out for
drinks afterwards
and like you know
even if you know them like a lot of
people know me and they're like how do
you feel about Aaron Rodgers like that's
they want you know that's the question
right I believe people are going to ask
people hey what are you collecting
you know how's your collection going
between art and watches and sneakers and
handbags
trading cards nfts I'm aware of where
that market is but the reality is to
your point Beanie Babies didn't work out
but stuff that plush toys are forever
stipend Germany gunned the teddy bear
Raggedy Ann like you know you know
digital Collectibles will be here for
the rest of our lives
um trading cards at the show everyone's
like where do you see the future of the
Hobby in five years do you think it'll
be around them like it's been around for
since the 1860s there's been trading
cards they were presidents and animals
back then now they're athletes in pop
culture but you know I think
where do you sit as someone who I really
respect on this in the genre of like are
you a buyer and I know we're both
enthusiasts but because we're how old
are you my friend
um I'm gonna be 50 in a couple months
happy birthday on a big one we've
watched this for the last 30 years
do you what and I saw you kind of react
when I said that do you sense
that I'm right about that and what and
and then expand on it like why what are
you seeing because I really I'm like oh
my God this is happening everyone is
going to recognize that everybody
collects your aunt might collect magnets
somebody else might be collecting
marbles somebody's got a grandma that's
got little elephant statues trading
cards are now mainstream you know like
Pokemon Yu-Gi-Oh obviously with with the
friends
we we announced you know the TCG
and now people understand why there were
numbers at the bottom of these cards you
know like that whole world is real
that's a game changer that really is
trading card games are enormous but get
me to the punch line yeah to answer your
question I mean like absolutely number
one fandom has become so much more
acceptable over the years I mean keep in
mind when I entered the toy industry a
toy executive or founder or entrepreneur
would rarely have all this stuff behind
them it would even if they're in the two
industry even if how many times you
remember 20 years ago you talked to
somebody who was in the entertainment
business they'd say I don't really watch
TV and you're like what you know what
you don't watch TV this is what you do
like get
room dude
I just think what's happened you know
I'll give you a related Story 2 000 year
2000 went to Comic-Con and it felt very
alt culture and people talked about it
as Fanboys fangirls nerds like nerdum
to your point I'm starting to jump in
I'm just so excited I apologize
everybody but like in the same way that
hippie culture was so old culture so
many things of the hippie year in the
60s are today normalized around the food
the you know mindset the music right it
your point in 2000 it felt really like
super nerd culture and today it just
like the biggest mainstream pop stars
are wearing a Dragon Ball Z t-shirt or a
Bert and Ernie like hat or what have you
yes yeah I mean like so basically it
went from 40 year old virgin which was
considered weird and yeah Steve Carroll
was hilarious but he was basing his
character on that alt culture so today
every mainstream stream content
distributor or Creator All actors
writers everyone wants to be at these
big shows to where they can show off all
of their fandom and you saw that at the
national so whether it's San Diego
Comic-Con or whether it's a big card
show whatever it may be what you're
seeing out there is our desire as humans
to connect with one another over
something that we have in common fandom
is a great thing to connect on we have
fandom in common we might have a brand
in common maybe we'll have sports in
common but it is all about commonality
and Breaking Free of the old restraints
that people used to have so you know if
you think about the old restraints they
were ridiculous they were based on
genetics but guess what we have a lot
more in common than that personality
types are way closer than a genetic pool
and I think what's going on is today
we're connecting over things that really
make us feel good about ourselves and
make us feel good about where we are in
a very complicated world so I'm noticing
more and more fun stuff behind people
when I'm talking to them yeah it's
actually one of the very first things
that I end up talking about it may be
because of my unusual position in the
world of being a toy maker or a
collector but the bottom line is
everything that you're saying is coming
to fruition in real time so the last 20
years has had this huge sea change in
terms of what is considered acceptable
and how you represent yourself I believe
that the next 20 years is going to be
even very very interesting you know
people are discounting and I'm I make
physical product okay and I've made
fiscal product my whole career but
people are discounting the concept of
digital as well because let's let's just
I'm gonna grab something off my shelf
okay while you do that I want to answer
Jonathan T's question why did it benefit
squishmallows to collaborate with VF big
fan of this just the incense incentive
if you could explain it might be a
little bit of a hard hitting question
for you Jeremy but I'd love to get your
answer
oh I mean it just it listen it's a
meaningful community of people that care
about each other and the basis of V
friends is you guys even say it's a
physical manifestation of metaphysical
traits that improve your lives uh
personal growth it's a great message so
yeah of course you know and in addition
to that the characters are very much
fitting into the squish Mellows Universe
I mean if you look at the characters
that are behind Gary right now whether
it's adventurous astronaut or humble
Hedgehog or intuitive iguana or Karma
kiwi these characters
are really easily adaptable into a
squishmallows form so while that's you
know I watched Gary create V friends and
I watched him draw those characters and
it was really inspiring to me I thought
it was very very impressive the way you
iterate and the way your brain works and
and you were entering into the digital
space but to create a franchise that was
native to the digital space at the time
and you know from my perspective what
you guys did with us is you said look
make it a squish Mallow and make it a v
friend based on so so we weren't given
constraints if you had come to us and
said it's got to look exactly like RV
friends it would have been too
constraining I mean look by the way
that's what we do that's what we do with
some of our other major brands so you
can see whether it's Pokemon or whether
it's something like the friends it
really is squishmallowized and it all
makes sense another beautiful community
that where we can touch and we can
associate and we can expand our message
and expand yours that's a beautiful
thing this astronaut is gonna I'm
predicting because uh real quick for
some info the law we launched the
collaboration in a week or so on the
seventh in the U.S it's going to be on
your website right yes yes is that on
the squishmallows website yes yep and
internationally it's going to be on
shop.vfriends.com but I'm making some
predictions just knowing the Be Friends
Community this astronaut is going to be
tough to keep in stock we've also doing
a little wink wink if uh when are they
what are they do and you may not know
this Jeremy and we'll have the team do
it
um yeah they Blondie you're absolutely
right by the way big shout out to your
team we knew we were walking into one of
the most important you know IPS and
collaborations so we wanted you to be
able to do what you needed to do but you
converted our characters into something
just absolutely remarkable we're just so
happy with the way they look I mean
here is my original drawing
with the lighting right right there's
the original drawing here for Instagram
like it's like it's pretty darn neat how
good of a job you were able to do to
convert it into something and so but you
know I think what uh what I'm excited
about is we've got a little bit of a
wink wink too we are we are going to
Comic-Con with be friends in New York
City
so that's a big announcement for
everybody's watching we will be at the
Javits Center which is a hop and a skip
from my office
and and
do you Jeremy do you know when these are
shipping
uh um my team know because that wouldn't
be online Jeremy's full detail I believe
we have them in our domestic stock I I
need to triple check but I don't think
they're shipping very far after the
orders are being taken but I don't want
to mislead anybody because I don't have
it look at Clarity on that the team will
let us know but we're hoping that if
these are being delivered in time and
you're going to
New York Comic-Con to bring your
squishmallow to us we got a little bit
of a fun thing so we'll make sure those
are work uh but methong what happened to
the nfts we work on them every single
day this is back to that digital world
we know that the nfts it's kind of like
Transformers had a Saturday morning
cartoon and a toy in Toys R Us in the
80s but then there were stickers and
gift cards like building an IP you do
them in many forms the nft is the Alpha
Series 1B friends is the punch line
um of like our collectible universe but
we build you know from our standpoint
why squish mode as you can imagine this
is gonna be Discovery for so many people
so many people are so infatuated with
this product that this is going to be
discovery of these characters and that's
a very very very big deal for us
yeah and and I first of all thank you uh
you know swishmallows has been a dream
because it's a platform it's it's a
blank canvas for us to apply a lot of
different brands on it you know who else
has done a great job with that I'll call
out another company is Funko and Pops so
they have a beautiful platform in terms
of the way that they can do plastic we
have a beautiful platform the way you
can do plush
um
but yeah I mean I think I think that
really covers the reason why we wanted
to do business with you but another
thing that I just like to say I just
address is the idea of a physical versus
a digital asset and and how much they
actually have in common because I think
a lot of people go oh it's a physical
collectible okay and maybe it's got
maybe it's valid because of that and
this is a digital collectible and maybe
there's some something that they feel
invalid because of that well let me give
you a quick
tutorial it'll take 10 seconds to
explain the difference between a
physical and a digital good okay so this
is a replica this is not real it's a
replica of an illustrator PSA 10 okay my
buddy dub Z I went to Dubai and it was
part of that transaction the five
million dollar card but let's just say
for a moment this is real okay and let's
just say this is a five million dollar
Real Deal which is not but let's just
say it is
it is nothing more than a piece of paper
so over here you have a digital good
with the intrinsic value being zero okay
outside of hard work that was put into
it there's no physical intrinsic value
over here you have something that is a
physical good with an intrinsic value
that may just be a couple pennies
so at the end of the day what makes a
digital property valuable over time is
the continuity of the license or whether
the person who's managing the IP
actually is managing and developing a
long-term franchise plan
and number two it really comes down to
whether the there is a um too much other
conflict oriented stuff happening in the
market imagine for a moment if Pokemon
had issued 300 000 different card sets
none other stuff would have the value
that it has right now you had nfts going
from a scenario where you had a hundred
programs that were viable to a thousand
to a million to tens of millions that's
right a very short period of time you
set it from day one 99.9 of them are
going to go to zero I happen to agree
with you I actually
that's the case that's the case with
everything I was at the National Sports
Bar 99 of sports cards are zero
it's well it's true it's just 99 of Art
is around 99 of watches are zero 99 of
sneakers is zero
you know every people always get
confused about that now with new things
like nfts like sports cards sports cards
Jeremy
from the 1920s to the 1970s 50 years
people didn't see the collectible value
in them people were putting Mickey
Mantle rookie cards in their bike spokes
yeah people you know like like things be
sneakers if I knew what Jordan Ones were
worth in 1985 would have bought them for
40 bucks and kept them or 100 bucks or
whatever they were
you know and so like things always ebb
and flow but let's go back to
um a couple of functional things because
we've got a lot of people and I haven't
been able to jump in and that's the the
Friends team to jump into all the
comments so they'll be helping you with
Logistics
um we are launching a just a reset for
everybody who's joined us squish bellows
NV friends are coming August 7th uh 2023
we're so excited
um and what we need right now I'm gonna
need you to change the copy here Dustin
is a lot of people are pounding us right
now even my admin said your inbox is
full of questions on how they get this
couple things
um we are going to give everybody the
first announcement first lead from the V
friends account so go to befriends.com
and create an account
defriends.com create an account
um even if you don't own an nft because
that will get you when you sign up for
the email newsletter and text you'll get
the info first so if you can make the
copy go to befriends.com to get and sign
up for an account to get the info up
first fold that on the bottom
um it's coming out next week
in the U.S it's going to be on
squishmallow's website exclusively in in
international buys it's going to be on
v-france website on shop.b friends we're
really excited about this we apologize
in advance for sellouts we're not
reprinting we've got
260 plus characters hopefully if this
goes well for Jeremy and team and goes
well for us these aren't the only four
characters we ever do uh we are going to
be at Comic Con in New York City in
October hopefully if Logistics get this
to you in time and we'll update you
um about this if we know that they're in
people's hands we do want you to bring
your squishmallow to the booth we've got
a plan
um and a little surprise if that all
works so there's some exciting stuff
going on here as we continue to build
this intellectual property V friends was
just at the national sports card
convention where we dropped the new TCG
game we had our first tournament it was
super excited we had thousands of people
discovered the brand Jeremy I know
you're paying attention always oh is it
on jazwares.com
is that true germ I'll I'll double check
I imagine that it would be on either but
uh it could be it could be either on
jazzware's vault program
um or squishmallows.com but I'll triple
check go to go to befriends.com create
an account make sure you get the news
letter if you really want to move fast
because you're you've got a crazy
uh squishmallows family or your crazy V
friends person you might want to get on
the tech stuff uh and get the text
because that's even faster but we're
really excited about this got the
astronaut The Adventurous astronaut the
humbled Hedgehog the karma kiwi and the
intuitive iguana will be the first
launch with uh with squish fellows um
were you paying attention from home on
the national sports card convention any
observations from the social content or
anybody on the street or is that is that
a world that you guys are further away
from
you know what I'm I'm very connected to
it just as a collector
um but I so I I what I what I picked up
on was just the the scale of it you know
like I said I've seen Comic-Con grow to
a couple hundred thousand people
watching the Nationals grow to over a
hundred thousand was uh eye-opening um
and seeing people after the Nationals
close trading on the floor and
continuing expanding the the footprint
of a giant show because of their love
and fandom and desire to be part of that
Community was pretty awesome
um I also heard that things were pretty
expensive and that a lot of the deals
weren't really being done until some of
the last days which also makes sense
because a lot of people are being uh
they realize how hot that that physical
space is you know what Gary I'd like to
address one additional thing that you
mentioned and that is you know talking
about V friends and what happens when
you develop a franchise so
yes the native component of V friends
was V friends series one nft program but
when you become a franchise you're not
native to any particular category of
content you are everything you're you're
your consumer products program you're
your partners you are the TV or the
streaming that you put out just because
you were native to one area doesn't mean
that that's your only area it may just
be that is the originator and so I I do
think that that's something that people
in this interpret if something's born on
Tick Tock it doesn't mean it's always
going to be just a tick tock I mean are
you kidding me Harry Potter was just a
book right
you know I mean like like Looney Tunes
was a Saturday morning cartoon Raggedy
Ann I don't remember its first form
factor you know like you know James Bond
was a movie like like Star Wars was a
movie like you know Pokemon was you know
you know this actually was Pokemon
originally TCG then video game is like
that was a starting point right yeah it
it was really rapid fire I mean
Strawberry Shortcake was a was a was a
greeting card yeah yeah so Strawberry
Shortcake came from a little character
on a greeting card to say like happy
birthday or like I'm thinking of you and
became an iconic IP so people don't get
caught up over an origin story or or
otherwise I'm just a kid from Memphis
that doesn't have any connections people
always ask me Jeremy I'm like hey Gary
you're building out this brand and all
these other places what's that gonna do
for my nft I'm like if if if there
wasn't Marvel movies people wouldn't be
buying Deadpool comic book number one
that's right that's exactly right so
it's just part of the story it's part of
a bigger story when you're creating a
franchise you're creating something that
you want to be in a lot of places
big respect to George that's exactly
right James Bond was originally a a book
then it became a movie but everything's
starts in a singular place that's right
right uh a lot of the current IPS
started as video game form doc Super
Mario was a dude in a Donkey Kong game
in 82. yeah oh by the way Gary I'll tell
you again
the way we built our business was on
video game properties no other major toy
company was touching them we were up and
coming we were new we were fresh we got
fortnite Roblox Pokemon we got all the
big ones why because people are so
myopic
uh Karma kiwi oh real quick my team is
Farther Along on our plan than I thought
for the hardcore v-friends Community
this is specifically for you uh the
Thursday of Comic-Con is a very good day
to be there I'm gonna leave it at that
that's the alpha spread it to all the
other hardcore
um we don't want to make it too big but
I feel like this is the appropriate
place to put the first seed of of uh of
Alpha and I know that the community will
share that and I want to make sure you
plan your travel schedules as you make
it so the Thursday of Comic-Con is going
to be the day you want to be there
minimally
um so
that is really smart so that's that's
borrowing from the page book of Magic
the Gathering Pokemon and many others
before you with your first edition or
Alpha Series is that what I'm hearing
well well we're we're we're doing like
we need a super sticker which I don't
think I have here but I was very
affected by the 1980s vending machine
stickers
you know the jewel you know so we
unveiled our super stickers at the
national
got it if you go to eBay right now and
type MD friend super sticker we really
did it right they only they weren't even
available at our booth
they were only given to the 6 000 VIP
bags for the people that ordered the VIP
package from the national itself so a
lot of friction to get them
so you know because I've been doing this
for 35 years and I've seen the stuff
that's been overpopulated under
populated the junk wax era what worked
what's working for you that didn't work
maybe for other things uh why Valiant
and spawn and Image Comics worked for a
little while but then didn't work you
know what happened organically with X Y
and Z that didn't for you know a b
you know I think as we enter these
places like Comic-Con what's unique
about V friends is I the human have a
very large platform and community
and the IP is Young
and obviously some of it's transferring
but you know to me you know what I loved
about the sports car National that will
be replicated the Comic-Con except I
think I have to leave for one day of
Comic-Con and come back but
I mean Jeremy peop there's people that
got to spend five minutes with me at the
national who've emailed me 337 times 400
PMS have gone to seven different
conferences with the hope of getting a
minute
to me what's great about I said to my
team last night on the flight home I
said man I'm gonna love building this
brand because this is blocking and
tackling this is being in the trenches I
was handing out these you know we're
doing this incredible thing with a
vending machine
um I might look this up uh Dustin get
over here because I'm gonna definitely
this up I need you to reset it but
you can see the top of it it's right
here this vending machine
right so we have vending machines coming
but these 50 Cent toys which I I did
this smart thing and I wait a minute
just lose it here we go I paid more Jim
you're gonna like this because you nerd
out on this stuff look how detailed my
little 50 Cent you can do with those
like my little alpaca here I like the
tooling yeah yeah the tooling I like you
know I paid more so it actually looks
like it yeah I guess so you could tell
right yeah it's hard to get those
undercuts in something unless you put
quality into it and it's this one smells
like bubble gum
oh that's good it's called the scent
there's Rarities you know it's a pencil
topper and like I'm really thinking
about building this IP and so you know
but I said to the team I said man this
is hand-to-hand combat this is I was
standing by the vending machine and
handing out little toys to kids walking
by giving them free cards like I'm
really serious about the hand-to-hand
combat of this game this is a
hand-to-hand combat game and this is not
an overnight thing the nft thing went so
high so fat like it got a little crazy
there yeah and it confused a lot of
things but like I said early on this is
a 20 30 40 year play for me and uh I'm
like really excited about it it's like
really really really really really
like I can't believe I got to pull off I
always thought that I would start a
marketing company and buy an IP
flat out I thought our building and I
was gonna buy Smurfs or Gumby or Popeye
and that's what I wanted to do
but you know nfts much like Saturday
morning cartoons much like video games
much like iPhone like the the iPhone
came out and created a format that
allowed Angry Birds IP to exist yeah
absolutely origin the origin that's
right nfts allowed me to launch be
friends but now I have to do everything
including nfts and web 3 and metaverse
and and it's just really exciting and
like I'm so up for the challenge because
I was happier the last four days sitting
on the floor pricing cards
talking to people like in the dirt you
know in the like I literally told the
team yesterday I want to go to the
Meadowlands flea market and just set up
a table
for hand-to-hand combat of like here's
how the game's played here's a little
toy kid here's you know some of the
squish Bellows anyway real quick I I
don't think we're gonna put out the
numbers but I can tell you if you love
the karma kiwi make sure you buy that
one first when the gates open next week
um because it's gonna be a little harder
than the others
they're definitely limited and it's it's
definitely a scenario it's it's
if you look at the Hang tag it's under
our select Series so we have
um several series of uh of hang tags one
is um are common and then we have rare
ultra rare and special edition and then
we have select series which is uh
the black hang tag so
I want people to learn the select series
means excuse me
so I came back from um our sales
meetings with a little bit of a cold
which everyone is mistaking is covet so
I'm like running around
keep going
excuse me
I'm back
go ahead my friend I was saying tell us
about the different Series so people who
don't know get educated
okay thank you yeah no so the everyday
series is the common series and that is
you'll find that on our non I would say
our everyday highest volume items rare
is lower quantity ultra rare is as a
gold bottom and it's
significantly lower quantities by the
time you get to special edition and
select you're in pretty rare air so you
guys you know that this is a very
this is a very
challenging and awesome product to get
your hands on
I mean what uh what's been the most
surprising thing for you in the last
year with squishmallows
um
I would say that the most surprising
thing hey my voice is back awesome
the most surprising thing
um about squishmallows in the last year
for me
has been every time we think we've hit
the plateau in terms of where this where
this is going to be in the zeitgeist
it continues to smash through it
um
and we want longevity we don't want a
phenomenon that is here and gone
so we're constantly under shipping and
that's by the way a piece of advice that
I have to anybody that's launching a
brand
um someone told me a long time ago a
mentor of mine
he said you know if you undership
something by a unit
you're a jerk he said if you overship it
by a unit you're a jerk he said so be
comfortable if you're manufacturing
products with being a jerk but don't
over ship because then you'll just be
out of business so don't capture every
dollar and and we didn't
um but it's amazing to me how things
continue to grow and evolve
um I do believe that what we have here
is an evergreen program much the way
that you've seen with Brands like Barbie
and much the way you've seen with Brands
like Hot Wheels or some of the wonderful
brands that Hasbro has we've just
created something with extra
extraordinary longevity and and I think
we've come to terms with that and our
partners have as well and so 20 years
from now hopefully we can you know
celebrate some Milestones together for V
friends and for squishmallows and and uh
toast to longevity because at the end of
the day that's the only thing that
matters
um what do you think about
this there's a question I'm asked a lot
and now I'm asking you not as a j you
know a Swiss a squishmallows exact I'm
asking you as a collector you the hero
people ask me a lot there's 268
characters and be friends I did that
because I want to do this forever I
think of it as Marvel that way which is
like it took years before they really
focused on black panther right right
people are asking me how did I pick
these characters right a I thought about
which characters would translate to
squishmallows well in squishmelo's form
like
the humbled Hedgehog is just cute as
hell in this form like like I think
people are going to land on your site
or like people that are fans of my
business content are going to show this
to their son or daughter and they're
like I need that so there was a little
bit of like this is the form factor
we're going in and the humble Hedgehog
matters but then also I think about
things like
thought you know six-year-old asking
their mom what this or dad what does
what does humble mean
and I actually think humility
is like one of the scariest things in
the world meaning if you were lucky
enough to develop it your life gets 73
000 times better yeah oh absolutely
that's one of our core pillars at jazz
Wares collaboration passion and humility
um humility is so underrated I will tell
you
um and the purpose of v-friends is be
competitive but do it in a nice way
right
and so I think humility is hidden
sometimes from people that are loud or
aggressive or you know strong like
people that a lot of people on my team
used to watch my content and then they
work for me and without a Shadow of
Doubt the most common theme is a year
later they're like
if they bring it up or if I'm like hey
what did you learn this year they're
like man from the outside in your
content it's hard to see the humility
from the day-to-day operations it's the
most obvious thing and so a lot of like
what I think about is like how do I put
to fall in love with traits that I know
are universally powerful
right yeah and that's why humble
Hedgehog was chosen on a 268 because I
thought it would look amazing and I
think it I mean this is like stunningly
cute to me personally subjectively like
astronaut's cool but this is like
ridiculously cute
but where are my questions going so here
oh I'm sorry no I'll just add one thing
to that and say some of the greatest
brands in the world have extreme breath
of line but then they also have Focus so
even if you're talking about like WWE
they have their top of the card Talent
they have their main card talent and
then they have their you know off TV
Talent you know Star Wars
um Pokemon well my favorite Star Wars
character was because I entered this
this week at the national during a Star
Wars Patrick my favorite Star Wars
character by a country mile is Greedo
yeah
that's awesome I mean literally I don't
know what's his screen time in all nine
movies like 18 seconds
yeah like I but when I was five he was
green on green
I was already a Jets fan like like or
like green was already my favorite color
which probably led to Jetson or whatever
I don't believe it's a little blurry but
like Greedo is my guy
that's who you connected with and by the
way that's part of when again at
Comic-Con this year I'm walking around
and what I notice is that the the
costumes and the fandom is getting more
and more obscure and more and more
specific to people so yeah having a
brand that has less Superman more fourth
tier a lot you know more Rhino from
Spider-Man and then less General
Spider-Man more Spider-Man from this
specific comic that was viral yes is
that what you're saying yes and starting
with that many characters just means
that it gives you the leeway to do a lot
of very cool things over a long period
of time and that's you you were right
with Marvel that's what you're saying
you've seen it in you've seen it in all
kinds of great Brands uh if you limit
yourself then then you uh then you set
up a whole new set of problems
back to the supply thing like one thing
I'm scared about with this drop is the
quick sellout we we made a good we we
felt confident with how many uh National
exclusive pins we made
by the way this is going to get the
whole view friends pin community
like actually let's go into that Jeremy
I don't think I understood what goes on
in pen life isn't it great no no it's
beyond we did at the Nash Our Vicon we
like it is taking on a life well it's
not released yet which is like the pin
thing in V friends if you go to be
friends pin on eBay right now like the
pin thing
I don't think I had a sense of how
insane
like it's a multi-generational uh
collectible category and you can think
about it think about it of all the
Collectibles you can remember that maybe
a grandparent had Coins Stamps and pens
pens on people's hats or they'd go to
Disney and they'd come back with a whole
are you the Disney thing I knew the
Olympics thing I crushed on Flipping
Olympic pins at garage sales Olympic
fields to garage sales to was like some
of my best flips oh awesome so you
realize how contemporary the pins thing
was it's like banana so anyway we like
first day half day with a limit on it
done with pins
wow you know I think with this we we put
real numbers into our production in the
scheme of where I think our communities
demand is so I feel confident that
people won't sell out I'm a little
worried about the Kiwi but like in
general and I think the astronaut's
popularity is going to be a beast and I
think then this the Iguana
and the and the humble Hedgehog are so
cute like literally somebody's landing
on your website that has never heard of
me the friends it's just gonna be like I
want that so we had a real strategy now
we think about it but how do how do in
the collector's world how do you think
Brands handle it best I'm even taking
away your world I'm talking to Jeremy
The Collector now when they do have
sellouts you know how do they how do
they how do Brands handle that well for
the people that might be doing limited
edition merch or things in their world I
think when you're I think when you're a
brand whole I think when you when you're
controlling a brand when you're the ipu
owner I think being very transparent
with the community is the best way to go
and for me what I often say is that
exactly what I said to you before if you
overship a brand if you overship
something it is the fastest way to the
end of that brand either retail hates
you because they're stuck with stuff
that they can't even sell at a discount
yep or you were in a scenario where the
secondary Market of anything that people
has purchased has collapsed because the
supply was too great for something that
you're putting out there so I think just
being very transparent communicating to
the community that you're never going to
overship that you're going to assess
and that each time you drop maybe you'll
extend the supply a little bit in order
to find where that equilibrium
equilibrium is but the best brands in
the world make themselves the word's not
exclusive because the objective is not
to be exclusive the objective is
longevity the objective is longevity and
Longevity means that you can't overship
so yes limit Supply until you have an
absolute definitive understanding of
where your equilibrium is and I think
being very open about that is the key
um as we wrap up here
just how where can people find you
because I think you're bigger executive
that you are and you're a great
executive but you're a great collector
voice where can people find you
um well personally I I guess on uh
on Instagram or what was formally named
is Twitter uh you can find me I think
do we have to call it X now like is the
like do we call it X I don't know I
don't know but I'll tell you this guy
this guy talking about a disrupter this
is a disrupter right here this gentleman
I've never seen anybody go into a brand
um and wipe it clean of its former uh
branding especially when it's one of the
key brands in a space it would be like
Disney changing their name to one letter
word it who knows what's gonna happen
this is actually a little Alpha you know
I'll put it as an Easter egg what do you
think about fictional characters or
non-athlete trading cards because that
is a Vibe I got from this show
like that there's a little more room for
the it's that it's start we're starting
to see a little something like you just
threw up a entrepreneur's rookie card
yeah I think you got to be careful I
mean I think I think the bandwidth is
only so broad okay and if you start
creating the same systems of
collectibility for absolutely everything
that you do for traditional trading
cards there is a Tipping Point and even
with Rarity there's a giving point and
so I I do think that and I'm kind of
hopeful that you know now that there's a
little bit more concentrated management
and development in that card space and
you can I'll just call it a spade
Fanatics is jumping in and doing a lot
there
My Hope Is that they do exactly what
we've talked about which is slow
controlled growth over time and trying
things that allows them to have
longevity because at the end of the day
remember that deal with Tops baseball is
70 years old
you know it was 1952 71 years old so be
in it for the long game be in it for
legacy and my hope is that know that
they don't try to turn absolutely every
possible category into the next way to
have a one-of-one parallel yeah of
course you do that you know there's only
so much to go around and what about TCG
games I know you're so deep Pokemon like
you know I I cannot believe what
happened on our tournament one of the
you know I made a really smart decision
and hired Consultants from the outside
to develop really smart
I'm really glad I did a dream like
honestly like they came back with
something I couldn't even comprehend
like did you know and
the poker so our game has this poker
Dynamic to it that is
literally the semi-final round of our
first Alpha tournament
at the national both guys had sunglasses
on it literally was like World Series of
Poker they're literally World Series of
Poker and they're looking at this card
in their deck awesome and they're like
looking at the numbers down here you
know as you can see here
and I'm like watching this and I
understand
we've got like 50 people surrounding
them the live streams are going crazy
the tension was super real and I looked
at my best friend Brandon who I grew up
with since I was 14 and my buddy moose
from college who used to go with me to
Toys R Us at like 7 A.M wait for the
stock guys to get there to get the hard
to get action figures
and I just had this moment of like my
God I'm always blessed and I've been on
gratitude gorilla my whole life but like
am I really at the Forefront of this
thing like I can like this is insane
like I can't wait to go to Every hobby
shop every gaming shop and one by one
get kids to plays because I think we got
something here
what do you know about TC that's magic
Yu-Gi-Oh Dragon Ball Z what what do they
do well what the what what do you have
to watch out for what's your take on TCG
TCG is one of the most powerful areas
that you can possibly get into if you
create the right platform of gaming and
it is really smart to work with people
that have done it before when you're
developing your own plan and and I got
to tell you beyond anything else as as
someone who's been around a company from
day one being a day one founder in the
toy space myself
um it's hard to look outside when you've
got so much talent yourself okay that's
about that's about humility and being
humble to say just because I know
something about this just because I was
at the Inception of something yes
doesn't mean that I don't need help
in order to make something great so the
number one thing you said just then that
hit me was that is very smart that you
worked with people that have probably
been in trading card gaming for decades
because they live and breathe the
underlying platform you know real way
and then attaching that platform to the
right brand and doing it in a way allows
you to have longevity which I think is
again key to everything and so yeah
trading card games in my opinion pound
for pound
if you look at Native Trading Card Game
properties they have longevity they have
enormity
they have Community they have all of
these things that make for something to
last and uh I think that uh if you're
establishing a system where people can
play a thousand times
and have sort of different exciting
things happen each time
and then have something at stake
um and then have something attached to
the fandom
um you're doing the right things there
to develop something that will last for
a long time couple things Thomas says Be
Friends card game is so boring two
things on that front it's not the basic
war that we came out with we actually
launched the Alpha Rules of the actual
game this Saturday but if you're
referring to that because you watch the
stream for an hour that's the beauty of
the whole thing some people find this
game boring but they love Yu-Gi-Oh some
people fight Pokemon most amazing thing
and they don't like magic magic is like
a culture that I admire so much like
some other people play poker some play
chess like that's what's awesome about
the world right like and it's on
multiple levels and I think that's what
the person writes like some people just
collect it to look at it and they look
at it as art some people collect it
because they want to play casually and
then some people want to collect it
because they play at a level that is so
deep because they know how all the
hundreds of characters interact and the
strengths and the weaknesses and how
these things happen so it's only as
boring as the amount of time that you
put into it and how compelled you are to
learn about it or the game wasn't
developed well like I could tell you
that was the biggest thing I took away
from the reason I pinned that guy's
comment on Instagram is I respect that
like chess might be boring to me it's
not but let's just uh poor cheesy might
not be the game for me but like but
anything that a lot of people do like
the crossword puzzle on Sunday I don't
want to do that but I recognize that
people do and thus I respect it to no
end classical music might not be my jam
I have friends in their 20s who can't
wait to get home and have a nice bottle
of bourbon or Japanese whiskey or a
glass of wine and listen to it I want to
listen to an emerging hip-hop artist I
mentioned Greedo Greedo the rapper O3
like people have different tastes
and I'll leave with that one of the I'll
leave with this and I'll give you the
last word Jimmy
we need to get into and culture I heard
a lot of people at the national and I'm
gonna see the Comic-Con as well just how
people do it you fall in love with
something so much you decide that you
think you're on other things
because of your thing oh why are people
buying magic cards they should just be
buying basketball football cards are the
best vintage versus new let people
collect what they want love your thing
and don't tear down other things
right that's the collecting genre I
might not maybe I'm surprised by you
know pins because it wasn't my jam but
the sneakers thing that we're doing with
Reebok I understand because I understand
sneakers right like and so I think that
letting it be a and game as a final part
like like cheer for other I don't
collect marbles many do I'm you know
like let people collect what they want
to collect and be happy for them because
there's room for all of it just because
you're not just because they're not
collecting your thing don't be selfish
and want them to so your thing goes up
understand that there's a million ways
to collect and be and be into and versus
or
yeah and on that same Vein on the and
vein the next big thing is still coming
and that's always going to be the case
whether it's the next way to enjoy
content or the next way to play or the
next way to collect and it could be you
that actually develops it once when I
say you I mean anybody that's actually
well that's why I did this for an hour
Jeremy thank you for being on Deal real
quick he said super stickers for Europe
International people not only is that
because we have 268 characters and there
will be a super sticker for all some of
these super stickers are only going to
be available internationally so we have
a lot of fun ways we're going to
distribute we're going to push the
boundaries of distribution and how uh
everybody will see you next week go to
befriends.com create an account you
don't need to own an nft to have an
account on befriends.com you want to do
that if you want to get the squish
mellow collab Jeremy thank you for being
on we'll have more info for all of you
love you have the best day see ya